[Music]
all right can I take your order excuse
me
what would you like sir can you wait
isn't that your job aren't you a waiter
[Music]
could you turn your phone down kid this
is a restaurant it just so happens I
have anxiety that means I have trouble
being around Pathan who won't leave out
full hello Eric
shut up by an exciting okay hey I'm on
my mouth you're about to get hit by a
car
alright that's it everyone stop stop
right up listen up people
I have anxiety that means I'm in my
shell and have a hard time expressing
myself I find it difficult to engage
with others so everyone shut up stop
because my anxiety is up here right now